and we start at the u.s southern border
tonight where america's hottest new
destination seems to be del rio texas or
as illegals might call it bidenville
has a nice ring to it right population 8
10
12 000. who knows the situation on the
border is spiraling out of control as
shocking footage showed twelve thousand
mostly haitian illegal immigrants
crammed under a bridge in south texas
last week and they're still there
right now
things are so bad it's not just
republicans sounding the alarm as
obama's dhs secretary jay johnson well
he's also crying uncle
we have to get control of our borders
200 000 a month is a lot of people dhs
just released the numbers for august
it's 200 000. august is typically a
month where it's very low
and those kinds of numbers and the
images you just showed your audience
saps the ability it overwhelms the
ability of dhs the border patrol ice
overwhelmed
unable to ignore the crisis any longer
the white house sent current homeland
security secretary alejano mariokas down
to texas today with a
shall we say weak message for these
illegal immigrants
we are very concerned that haitians who
are taking this irregular migration path
are receiving false information that the
border is open or that temporary
protected status is available i want to
make sure that it is known that this is
not the way to come to the united states
that is false information if you come to
the united states illegally you will be
returned
uh-huh
but where is this so-called false
information coming from why do tens of
thousands of illegals regardless of
where they're coming from think the
border is open
maybe it's because joe biden has spent
all this year and last year on the
campaign trail rolling out the
borderless welcome mat
or maybe suspending deportation flights
to haiti earlier this year gave this
group of illegals all the encouragement
they needed to rush the border
and of course the media
on top of the situation
pressing jensaki today on what is
clearly the most important issue
you're allowing afghans to come in
afghan supporters
to come in as well as mexicans and then
haitians are not allowed can you speak
to that the issue of equity and fairness
can you speak to that let's play by that
left wing game for a second
why are they turning away these black
people
are they not the right color to cross
the border why do some black and brown
illegals get to claim asylum and be
treated with compassion
but others get deported
why does bidenville get targeted with
draconian measures like deportation
this is the group you get tough on
poor illegals
yearning to live free
bidenville is the literal depiction of
the huddled masses
yet joe turns them back
sounds pretty racist to me
surely comrade ocasio-cortez will be
there to cry for their plight like she
was at the donna facility
or maybe mayor joe biden will deport her
too there are no rules
and others are just arbitrary so so who
knows
but no
she wants to tax the rich like really
bad
so so she's safe
every other day the voters open but
today it's closed for black haitians in
bidenville
what is the standard
what is the plan at the border maybe the
plan is
no plan the only thing joe biden is
trying to avoid at the border is bad
media coverage
and he's even bad at that
meanwhile patriotic border patrol agents
and texas law enforcement are put in
impossible situations
babysitting at bidenville while the
mexican cartels take full advantage
you heard jay johnson say 200 000 are
crossing the border in august
with all the holes being created along
the border
i'm sure the number is much higher
and where was mayor joe biden this
weekend well he was making sure things
are all good up there in delaware
while licking ice cream cones and
mask-less bike rides how dare he
as crisis after crisis explodes under
his leadership or non-leadership
but don't worry vice president giggles
was on the case
you'd figure root causes kamala would be
posted up in port-au-prince figuring out
the real problems in haiti
but instead she was wandering around the
50-yard line at a football game in
washington dc flipping coins
heads the citizens of bidenville stay
tails they go
so it's obvious we can't count on the
white house to fix this crisis
but luckily our democrat-led congress is
doing something about it
they spent last week building a wall
putting the national guard on standby
and gathering the entire national media
so everyone could see what was happening
no not on the border but instead outside
the u.s capitol
as texas is literally overrun with
illegal immigrants our self-centered
leaders in the swamp are erecting walls
that apparently work and calling in the
national guard over a tiny peaceful
protest and of course predictably the
left-wing media lapse it all up you see
democrats don't care about protecting
you
or me or the border or our nation
they only care about protecting
themselves their political position and
their livelihood
and that's why they're ignoring the
border it doesn't affect them except
they hope in the future
at the ballot box
so they're focused on shoving a instead
of shoving a 3.5 trillion dollar
socialist spending bill down our throats
fundamentally changing our country and
economy in the process barack obama
talked about fundamental transformation
he never would have dreamed of a bill as
rich as the 3.5 trillion dollar bill
they're trying to pass
the border crime covid inflation all
distractions
mayor joe biden
vice president giggles and their
usefully useless dhs secretary had they
have bigger plans and they're determined
to pass 3.5 trillion of them
your safety and sovereignty
just don't matter in comparison